ok questo erano soltanto tre delle
miliardi di minchiate che sono successi
in questo video buona visione ragazze e
ragazzi grazie a quest'uomo
siamo entrati alla festa di youtube
[Musica]
ragazzi miei la mitropa da ragazzi
allora questa è la festa di youtube
mondiale ci sono tutti youtuber più
potenti nel mondo tranne più di file
abbiamo tutte tranne più difatti
panorama tigerlily giuseppe vegas
stefano lepri ma cos'è lo spagnolo è
come ultimo ma non ultimo surreal
facciamoci un serpico la dj tutti
ubriachi ciò dice
perché ho fatto questa cosa bella sono
rimorchiata gaza
cosa che tutti youtube e reso più di era
andata al culo ma vado da qualcuno tutta
you tube mondo ok ragazzi siamo fuori
dall'hotel e stiamo per prendere
l'autobus per andare alla convention
oggi il secondo giorno di commercio
terzo giorno a mano
ma entriamo sull'autobus ragazzi
ovviamente mezzo vuoto trame questi tre
cristiani e informare lega è perché sono
un primi nomi devo fermare qualche tu
fai casino se infatti ma [ __ ]
sediamoci 4 10 notificata veramente non
ci credo mai che c'è il sesso pensa che
i minchioni che c'è tutto l'autobus
ruote noi ci siamo messi quale linea
della scala puoi cantare così sappiamo
cosa balli mentre la palestra
questi c'è volevamo chiederlo a te così
da vi ba v
[Musica]
il bracciale entro
no arezzo
il pezzo di me l'hanno rischiato la vita
per colpa tua
ecco il pari con gli parlo
[Musica]
zio è preso qualcosa no no come sempre
un sacco di roba un sacco di capelli
fighissimi tra l'altro guardo guarda
alla fine un compro casa o porca [ __ ]
torniamo in camera sì la musica non
poteva chiesta la nostra stanza porco 2
sempre con la musica manetta scozzaro
lazzaro landia è il mio letto quello
legislativo vuole l'autografo il nome ad
elezioni
bye bye
ok ragazzi miei siamo tornati in un
posto che non visito mai che si chiama
hollywood mai stato proprio stato di
cerri potter in gigantografia a rega
buongiorno how a trastevere ristorante
pizzeria vino barrese chiamiamo murer
faina nova per haga trastevere hollywood
[Applauso]
perché ragazzi questa la giocata della b
questa e della vita è enorme
prima devo capire che cazzo vogliono
abbiamo deciso il pop il porco e la
nostra
art l'illusione grandissima
allora ragazzi dopo tutta questa merda
di giocate si è suicidato un pupazzo
completamente da solo in un dottorato
giuro quando giochi a ste robe vinci dei
punti e ai punti poi li spendi per
prendere delle cose io facendo i giochi
o totalizzato 280 punti
un pupazzo della minkia tipo questo ne
vale 700
c'è quindi io devo andare sul meno del
meno del meno poiché faccio veramente
cagare ecco i punti che ho guadagnato
ragazzi posso permettermi di prendere
questo un asso vostra di gomma anche la
merda più merda tipo questo sono 500
punti e non ci arriva ok ragazzi abbiamo
beccato questo negozio che fa delle
specie di converse all star
personalizzate da puro egocentrico che
minchia manco michael jackson si sta
facendo leo state personalizzate con la
mia faccia il cazzo la mia faccia di
calcio che sta facendo tutti siamo vi
faccio vedere che cazzo sta facendo
[Musica]
quelle sono le scarpe in preparazione
non è questa qua e la grafica mostra di
gaza city grazie efficace e the fucking
26 pazienti cassini di grancassa delle
scarpe abbiamo preso veramente figo e
non sarà un gran colpo questo delle
scarpe perché quale fanno già eravamo
venuti l'anno scorso avete suo negozio e
quest'anno non ce lo siamo fatti
scappare all'ultimo perché dobbiamo
partire tipo stasera però ci siamo fatti
siamo tutti qui apposta praticamente
[Applauso]
e niente ragazzi si mostra mattina ero
in questo istante sono prettamente
vicino alla fifa la lazio se non avesse
i peli delle braccia lunghi come quelli
di cheetah hunt sarebbe meglio però
vabbè ci aspettano dieci ore di viaggio
di ritorno io voglio morire qua perché
si ricordati che abbiamo un ospite nelle
mezzo fase bruttissima prova e ci
vediamo poi all'arrivo io smette di
bloccare perché mi sto vergognando come
lo schifo perché ci sono ospiti
merli